[Music]
welcome back to another episode of
what's up prof
hello walter hello martin how are you
i'm fine thank you
so today we're doing some questions and
answering again
yes it seems that
they have been piling up
and some people are saying why don't you
do that because you know we have to so
many things that we can talk about yeah
at some stage we have to do some yeah
questions and answers again let's open
with a word of prayer
our heavenly father thank you very much
for this opportunity just to discuss
your word we ask that you bless us and
also enlighten our minds in jesus name
amen amen
so let's start with the first question
and see what we can get out of you
why out of me what about you what's
wrong with you
no i'll help
in the bible it states that god has no
pleasure in the destruction of the
wicked however there is one verse
that seems contradictory
psalm 37 verse 13 states
the lord shall laugh at him for he seeth
that his day is coming can you comment
on this please
well as you see we've put a verse under
that one right yes
and that is ezekiel 33 verse 11
say unto them as i live says the lord
god i have no pleasure in the death of
the wicked
but that the wicked turn from his way
and live
turn ye turn ye from your evil ways for
why will ye die
o house of israel
there's a rule in the bible
well let's not put it that way let's say
there's a rule in studying the bible
which states that you can only
extrapolate from the obvious text
to the obscure text
never take a text that seems problematic
to base your doctrine on
you always have to interpret it in the
light of one that is absolutely clear
so when you're studying the character of
god or any one of those statements the
classic one is that god
induced david to go and number the
people
and the contrary verse says that satan
induced him to go and number the people
now which one is it
well in the hebrew mind of course god is
in control of everything so even if he
permits satan to do something then in
their mindset it is he that does it
right
but he didn't do it because he wouldn't
tell him to do it and then punish him
for doing it that doesn't make any sense
yeah so people use these as
an argument that the bible contradicts
itself
so when god says that he has no pleasure
in the death of the wicked but that is
that he wants the the wicked to repent
and alter their ways
then that is a very plain statement yes
now when probation closes
either for humanity or for the
individual
then that choice can no no longer be
made because you have adamantly
made your choice correct
and if the consequences become too harsh
then there's no point in complaining to
god
yes the classic example again saul
he
complained bitterly
but he had made his choice
and
when
the contrary wins came
he felt sorry for what he had done but
not because of what he had done but
because of the consequences correct
another classic example
is esau
yes all right
he also sold his birthright yes and he
sorted with tears afterwards
but it was gone
he sought it not because he repented but
because of the sense of loss
so when god
laughs is that the same kind of mocking
laughter that we have
definitely no it's a laughter with a
tear in the mind
in in the eye right yeah yeah
so basically what the text is saying
that there's nothing more that god can
do for him because he's made his choice
his heart will not change
because if it could change
then it would have changed correct it's
sort of a laugh that you know that
i cannot yeah cannot do anything there's
nothing i can do about this situation
anymore you've made your choice yes
correct
so that's basically what we can say
about that text but that's very
important what you just said i think a
lot of people including myself we can
learn from that that you use the plain
text yes and then you go to the hard
ones because in any bible study take
take the state of the dead exactly the
wicked shall consume away they will
consume they will be smoked they will be
as though they never were yes that's the
plain rendering of the situation
now you take a symbolic text and you get
all muddled
you argue from the plane
to the complex never from the complex to
the plane thank you i think that will
sort out a lot of things if people start
doing that
please explain amos 4 7
has it passed or is it to come
and amos 4 7 states
and also i have withholding the reign
from you when there were yet three
months to the harvest and i caused it to
rain upon one city and caused it not to
rain upon another city one piece was
rained upon and the peace whereupon it
reigned not with it
okay what is god doing here
he is talking to his people
who have become obstinate and turned
their backs upon him yes
and he's explaining to them that he
tried to warn them
by using environmental examples and this
is a very interesting one
because it states that god
withholds the rain from one city while
he lets it rain on another one he
doesn't want to destroy humanity but he
wants them to realize
that
their choices
affect the circumstances
i like the one where he says i gave you
cleanness of teeth
in other words you had nothing to eat
i created a famine and still you did not
return to me
so this is a situation which is ongoing
for god's people
up till today since the dawn of of the
sinful nature
up until today
and today we call we call this climate
change don't we yes
yes but can god overrule
climate change yes
can god overrule man's intervention in
the climate definitely
yes but does he always no not always no
if if humanity has decided to throw god
aside
then the signs will multiply
but humanity being as stubborn as it is
will find this
another excuse
so now they will
say it is climate change right correct
so what the text basically means is that
god is in control of everything and when
circumstances become tough
they are signs from god and he mentions
many of them in matthew 24
that will occur
and people should take heed that god is
in control
but man thinks
that he is in control
but he is not
there's also of course
a spiritual aspect with regard to rain
in terms of the outpouring of the spirit
and
it can be withheld
and it can be supplied
according to the sincerity of those that
seek it okay thank you
there are people that say that in the
old testament
people didn't have the holy spirit
it was only after the outpouring at
pentecost that people received the holy
spirit
is this true
well why would
david
in the psalms write
that god should please not remove the
holy spirit from him
so the holy spirit has always worked in
the minds of men
but at pentecost there was a special
outpouring
to
instill in the minds of men that jesus
christ was the messiah correct so there
was just a shift
in the overall proclamation
function and was it also that they were
of one mind and receptable
to accept the teachings of the holy
spirit at that time
yes because they had by experience
recognized before that jesus was the
messiah
because peter
had acknowledged that jesus was the
messiah yes
and uh
thomas had acknowledged
that he was wrong in his skepticism
yes and he acknowledged my lord and my
god right
so
they were prepared because of their
experience and now they were empowered
to preach it with power
under signs and wonders to give emphasis
to the fact
that they had been with jesus
thank you
revelation 21 verse 8 states but the
fearful
and then it goes on to name a few other
things shall have their part in the lake
which burneth with fire and brimstone
which is the second death can you please
unpack this verse
in the greek it means
timid and faithless by implication
if i am struggling with being fearful
does it mean i'm lost
this is a very interesting
verse and this verse deals with
the time after the close of probation
who is lost and who is saved
and
the the list as you say is quite long
and some of them of course very obvious
the liar the murderer etc they will not
be part of the kingdom of god
but there is this category that the
questioner is concerned about and that
is the fearful
now does that mean that when i am afraid
that i am lost
how many people in the bible were afraid
a lot about everybody right at some
stage everybody
so obviously it doesn't mean that
so who are the fearful
who are the ones that are timid and
faithless remember that this deals with
after the time after the close of
probation so a decision has been made
correct a decision has been made
and that decision determines
the eternal outcome
uh
the issue at stake
particularly is the mark of the beast
yes
right and this fearful warning for those
that accept the mark of the beast
as to oppose as opposed to the seal of
god yes that is a choice that has to be
made
now obviously there's coercion
involved yes
because church and state the image of
the beast will place pressure on the
believers to follow a certain line of
thinking
and if you don't
follow that line of thinking
then
you will not be able to buy or sell
maybe you will be locked down and not be
able to attend any functions or
educational facilities
maybe if you continue in your stubborn
ways you will be placed on the house
arrest or even placed in jail
and so these laws do they exist now
already in terms of other issues
yes
could they be expanded to include
climate lockdowns and most
sunday laws and all of these yes
absolutely right
okay
now what if you decide
because you are fearful
of the consequences yes
that you will go along with the
mainstream
then you will have made your decision
now how will everybody know that your
decision has been cemented
if you join the crowd to turn against
god's people to condemn them
where your ultimate motive was you were
fearful of the consequences and we spoke
about that in the previous question now
uh saul
was fearful of the consequences
but his repentance
was not the repentance of the heart
so those are the fearful those
who go
along
with the status quo
now what about those for example
that are by nature weak
or incapable
because of mental disability
uh people that are incapable of
of this high-level decision
making
can still be fearful
now god will take all of that into
account
and the bible says that many will be put
to sleep
and will
wait in the dust for the coming of the
lord so there's a promise in the bible
the lord will not let you be tempted
beyond what you can endure yes so all of
that is packed into that verse yes so we
shouldn't read it that everybody who has
fear on occasion
would be lost yes it's when you act upon
that fear and you succumb to it that you
lose your faith
then it becomes a problem and turn
against
those
that are following god
if you call light darkness
[Music]
then you have reached the point of no
return
it's a very scary thing because it might
seem an easy way out and there's another
point
even the strongest
can be fearful oh yes
uh let's take an example out of the
bible peter i was thinking about that in
the beginning yes yes was he fearful yes
definitely and he wasn't
he wasn't when he was talking to jesus
then he was full of full of bravado yes
but when it came to the crunch
you think there will be a number of
peters at the end definitely so how do
you fortify yourself against that what
did peter do after he realized what he
had done
when he heard that crow for the
final time
well he did what jesus
said he hoped he would he repented he
ran
he wept bitterly he repented
and eventually became so strong that he
was prepared to be crucified upside down
right
so this is this is the issue
uh we have to be very careful and that's
why we have these examples in the bible
that we do not allow
this fear to cloud our judgment
and in order not to allow it to cloud
our judgment we must have absolute faith
in the promises of god
and may we have that i pray that
let's go to another another question
this question is regarding one of the
books in the spirit of prophecy
called truth about angels and it's and
this person asks
when i read on page 273 in truth about
angels which is under the heading
satan's personation after the close of
probation
i'm of the opinion that satan will
deceive people after the close of
probation and the target are those who
go through jacob's time of trouble
i am open to being corrected so any
clarity would be greatly appreciated so
let's maybe look at some quotes in the
spirit of prophecy to see if we can get
some clarification
okay
this one is
uh truth about angels page 273 the wrath
of satan increases
as his time grows short and his work of
deceit and destruction reaches its
culmination in the time of trouble
and the time of trouble of course martin
is after the close of probation yes
god's long suffering has ended
the world has rejected his mercy
despised his love
and trampled upon his law
the wicked have passed the boundary of
their probation and the lord withdraws
his protection and leaves them to the
mercy of the leader they have chosen
as the crowning act in the great drama
of deception satan himself will attempt
to personate christ
the church has long professed to look to
the savior's advent as the consummation
of her hopes
now the great deceiver will make it
appear that christ has come
in different parts of the earth satan
will manifest himself amongst men as a
majestic being of dazzling brightness
resembling the description of the son of
god given by john in the revelation
the glory that surrounds him is
unsurpassed by anything that mortal eyes
have yet be held
the shout of triumph rings out upon the
air christ has come christ has come
here's a summary in the book last day
events
and it says satan sees that he is about
to lose his case
he cannot sweep in the whole world he
makes one last desperate effort to
overcome the faithful by deception
he does this impersonating christ he
clothes himself with the garments of
royalty which have been accurately
described in the vision of john
he has power to do this he will appear
to his deluded followers the christian
world who have received not the love of
the truth but had pleasure in
unrighteousness
transgression of the law
as christ coming the second time
now we have two aspects
and they're slightly different in
the two quotes that we've read right yes
in the first one it appears that this
would be after the close of probation
here it could appear that it could be
before the close of probation
because it says
he makes one last desperate effort to
overcome the faithful by deception
now
if they are sealed
after the close of probation
then no effort to overcome them will
succeed because let them
that be faithful be faithful still
yes and that those
that aren't yes stay there stay there
so
which one is it now but this can also
be that he tries but doesn't succeed
yes that is true but
it would be a pointless effort the other
possibility
and some people see it this way
and i have no particular beef about
people seeing it that way
is that this effort that he puts into
into this final movement
is not so much to make
the righteous turn from their
righteousness because that is impossible
them having been sealed after close of
probation
but to rile up the wicket to the point
where they are willing to destroy them
yes i i can see how that can be possible
that is a possibility
so
either way there is an argument for both
sides of the story some see it that this
happens after the close of probation
and there is merit in that
and some see it that it is just before
the close of probation and there is
merit and that i think each one must
decide for himself for where he stands
on this issue and i think we have to
make sure that we understand and know
our bible
that lest we be deceived so when he
comes
and when he appears as a being of
dazzling light
we must know our bible yes because isn't
it true that we won't know if the time
of probation has closed no we won't know
exactly when it closes there won't be
an announcement that the time has
has come except the announcement in
heaven of which we are not part at that
stage yes so we have to be ready
either spite off either way
thank you
we must just be careful martin that we
do not take issues such as this
and make it
a issue of salvation whether you
understand it this way or that way
the salvation issues are
do you obey god and his precepts or
don't you
amen
all right yeah we've got four questions
two of them we'll just briefly answer
the last two
but the first two
is the latter rain falling now let's
start with that one maybe
well
the latter rain comes with a loud cry
and that takes place
after the shaking has taken place
so
the latter rain in its fullness is not
falling now
but the latter rain as spatterings
is falling
so
people's hearts are being prepared for
the events that are taking place
and there are little showers here and
little showers there
preparing the hearts and the of the
people for what is coming right
but the great outpouring
when there is the loud cry of god's
collective people after the shaking that
has not taken place yet
would you like to maybe
speculate on how far we are from there
you want to get me in trouble once again
now you can see who the instigator is
here
let us say near even at the door okay
that's a good answer thank you
does probation close for the adventists
first
the bible doesn't say that there are two
clauses of probation
it doesn't say that there is a close of
probation
that is what the bible says
let the wicked be wicked still let the
righteous be righteous still that is the
close of probation
but there is a verse in the bible which
says that judgment begins with the house
of god yes and begin with the elders
correct the leaders yeah for instance so
obviously there's there is a process
that takes place
and i wouldn't go so far as to say
that this judgment will be completed in
this particular denomination before the
next one starts
but the process
obviously begins with the house of god
thank you then
what does walter eat in a day and what
does martin eat in a day
food i also
tend to eat food during the days
well the last two questions i put in
because this is what
some people ask so
what does walter eat in a day and what
does what martin eat in a day what is
the recommended diet for
for the people of god right from the
beginning in the garden of eden yes
right through
the walk in the wilderness right through
to the time of the end
so plant-based and whole food
plant-based whole food yes so seeds
grains nuts legumes
vegetables
fruit yes
delicious
perfection of food spreads yes so
some people have their main meal in the
morning i know people that do that with
you know fully cooked meal in the
morning
we
me personally
i prefer grains and
and fruits
in the morning
yes and the main meal
later in the day
and i suffice
largely with two meals a day
but it's not a law of meats and persians
so if i've been very active
i will have something light in the
evenings
and
but basically i have my grains in the
morning together with fruits and spreads
and
interesting things like that and a main
meal in the afternoon but what do you do
well basically the same but one thing
you must mention
is there's a variety
oh yes and it's not always every day
exactly the same no that would be
exceedingly boring yes sir i always i
always give the example if you give
somebody
a little child 10 birthday presents
and he unpacks them and he likes one of
them takes a hammer and smashes the
other nine
that's the last time he gets 10 right
from now on you get one
so when god provided all these gifts and
all this bounty and you decide you're
going to only eat one
then
as a parent you would probably front and
say
why did i bother to make all the others
right correct
so variety is the spice of life
and the important thing to know is that
every single
plant
every single fruit
has different antioxidants in it
different nutrients in it
and they augment each other
didn't you
i'm sure you explained it one day
for instance an apple
it doesn't have as much v vitamin c in
it as an orange but there's certain
elements that makes the vitamin c in the
apple
more available available so
phytochemicals which enhance the
function yeah so you have an
enhanced function you know even if you
go to organic farming
you tend to
uh alternate
in in a in a bed
what grows above the ground with what
grows below the ground so in one season
you will say plant onions and
carrots and things like that which grow
under the ground
and on the same patch you will grow
things which grow above the ground
cabbages and lettuces and whatever grows
above the ground
because the nutrients
are totally different
that are taken out of the ground by the
various plants
so by alternating
you get this this nutrient mix i
understand
and by combining foods you also get a
rich smorgas board
of
antioxidants phytochemicals all of which
help you
with overcoming disease it's interesting
that we are seeing more and more
articles coming out that
in terms of this covet
crisis that the world is in
that those who are
plant-based have a
much higher probability of overcoming it
in a in a more
ameniable way than do others and these
are scientific publications nothing to
do
with religious organizations so exactly
the world realizes it correct yes so
let's stick to that kind of diet yes
definitely i will never be able to go
back
uh
just on this the subject here martin how
do you eat
what did you eat before
you ate this way
well maybe the standard south african
diet
okay which was
potatoes rice
and meat
and your main vegetable was chicken yes
yeah it was mine too
yeah
nose and then all all the other
all the other creepy crawlies and stuff
like
oh yes for variety yes yes so you put
one crawly and the and the creepy on the
next one right okay
now i'm glad we broke with that
definitely
do you know what's interesting martin
when i used to eat like i used to eat
i used to have this
dull feeling in the brain
and i've told the story before and i had
to give classes after lunch at the
university
it was a major schlep
because you have this fog in your head
and you're trying to get rid of it and
that doesn't happen anymore yeah it's
amazing now
your concentration level is on
something totally different and energy
levels yes and now of course we know
that you know if you have a meal
like the world has which is rich in in
fats free oils and fats
then you cut the oxygen supply
to your brain quite tremendously
and one cup of coffee
cuts the oxygen supply to your brain by
40 percent i mean can we really run on
just 60 percent brain capacity when it
comes to important decisions of life and
death
no and the problem is there's such a big
um argument going out there you've got
articles coming out on this side then
you've got articles on this side and
this the whole thing is being thrown
around it's like a wall war
you know what and the thing is it comes
back to a personal decision yes
absolutely so this whole war going up on
about people trying to impose their
decision on somebody else you know
what's important to me martin
is that the spirit of prophecy is very
clear
that your decision-making capacity
starts in the stomach yes
right
absolutely
and the science behind it is also
absolutely clear as i've already said if
you cut the oxygen supply
to your to your brain
and
you take substances which becloud the
capacity of the frontal lobes
in particular then obviously your
decision making is going to be
compromised right yes
so
and i know i know it's a harsh thing to
say
but perhaps one should
look at what goes into the mouth
before one absolutely puts one's trust
in what comes out of her mouth
definitely i agree with it i've been in
some i've been in some uh
meetings
where
there are meals involved in between
and by just
watching what goes on to the plate you
have fair idea of what comes out of the
mouth
yes i also tend to
observe that have you observed that and
it takes you back to the what we've
started with
on that revelation verse
that fearful and faithful if don't you
want to have
the optimal
capacity to
choose and if
a certain diet
has been proven
to give you a better clarity of mind
then maybe it's a good option to give it
a go not only that now people say you
know
what has this got to do with religion
now in my past i was heavily involved in
in new age thinking as well
and involved with people
that were in the new age realm
they take their diets very seriously in
order to have this connection with their
spirit world
and the people that i was involved with
when they wanted to have a particular
spiritual experience
whether they
were
people that had occult direct
communication
with spirit entities or whether they
were ufo fanatics they would go on a
fully plant-based vegetarian diet in
order to achieve that
and if you read the books of the new age
where
these spirit entities communicate their
will
they make it quite plain that you
shouldn't eat meat etc so to have a
clear communication
so even if even if
that is the case in spiritism yes and in
direct satan worship
then how much more so for god's people
definitely so i hope we've answered
with a rather long answer
yes sorry we get quite excited when we
talk about
we could turn it into a whole what's up
right i think i think we will we will
yes
here are two questions
do the angels in heaven keep the
seventh-day sabbath as we do
are the commandments in the ark in
heaven the same as given to man as
angels can't commit adultery etc as we
do
this is always a very interesting point
of discussion
the bible is quite clear
that the sabbath is part of this
creation yes
it came at the end of the sixth day of
the creation then
the seventh day
was made the sabbath
and it is also very clear that the
sabbath was made for man
now the reason for that is that man was
given dominion unlike the angels we must
actually
talk about another question that there
is at some stage regarding this issue of
the creation of man and the fall of man
etc
but the point is it was a creation for
man
it was made for man jesus is quite clear
of it and he said that he is lord of the
sabbath
now the angels had constant access to
god but man
had six days of labor
in which he could communicate with god
but not give all his attention to this
relationship so the seventh day
was introduced to make it possible for
him to have this intimate connection
find this rest in god
so the angels didn't keep it before then
because it was made for man
but the bible also tells us that it will
be a perpetual
event that will take place in the new
world
so angels will partake
in the future
and at the time that we are living in
when we keep the sabbath they
participate with us
definitely yes
so they're not keeping it in heaven
they join us on the sabbath on earth
correct and then in the new heaven
correct
we will be keeping it together correct
as a constant reminder
of our
origin
and our redemption yes
about who we acknowledge as our god
correct
and then the second question are the
commandments in the ark in heaven the
same
as given to man as angels cannot commit
adultery that's a
good question right
here's a quote in first selected
messages page 230
it says
that the law of god existed before the
creation of man or else
adam could not have sinned
after the transgression of adam the
principles of the law were not changed
but were definitely arranged and
expressed to meet man in his fallen
condition
christ in counsel with his father
instituted the system of sacrificial
offerings
that death instead of being immediately
visited upon the transgressor
should be transferred to a victim which
should pre-figure the great and perfect
offering of the son of god
so in other words
the law
was codified in a form to meet man in
his fallen condition
so
the principles were not changed
so the principles existed for all
eternity otherwise satan could not have
sinned correct
so iniquity
was found in him and that is the
transgression of
the principles of god's
government yes so even though the angels
can't commit physical adultery they can
commit spiritual yes adultery and
lucifer did and the fallen angels did
correct and the bible makes it quite
clear that if you break one
you break them
or
so let us say for example
you
covet
that's where his sin started right right
the throne of god yes he coveted it
so his first
seed of sin
was
coveting coveting
led him
to other sins
he insinuated
that god's government was not righteous
and not
fair in other words
insinuation is a form of lying
yes
right a mild form but it is a form of
lying
to insinuate something to plant an idea
contrary to the facts yes that's a lie
yes
so by coveting he started to
lie
eventually when you take it down the
road
he broke the first commandment which
says thou shalt not
have any other god i have other any
other gods beside me
and by elevating himself to a position
he was committing idolatry yes so he was
breaking the second commandment
he had to malign god in order to make
his case
that broke the third commandment
the fourth commandment
is a commandment which which was made
for man
but the principle of the commandment is
a relationship with god with god
and because he had already broken the
first one and the second one and the
tenth one and broken the one about lying
he broke that relationship so he broke
the fourth commandment
he dishonored his parent who is god
he broke the fifth commandment
he was prepared to kill him
and he did yes he broke the sixth
commandment
did he break them all yep did he commit
spiritual adultery yes
so by breaking one
he broke them all correct
so it is a principle that is eternal and
that's why it's so entrenched that's
god's character that's right he's
what did you say in the beginning
he's
government
of the universe it's the basis of his
government the foundation of his
government
is in his moral law yeah
is israel as a nation still the covenant
people of god
do the promises still apply to them
you know martin this is the big question
and the evangelical
world
hotly believes
that this dispensation
is actually still active alive and well
and living in israel yes right
so are they still the covenant people of
god
the new covenant points to salvation in
christ correct
correct
and it is based on better promises yes
the old covenant was made
with
israel now we must think about this
logically
the old covenant was given in type
the new covenant is the anti-type
the old covenant was the shadow yes
the new covenant is the substance
so now my question is
can the shadow
and the
substance be to covenants
i'm busy working on a series on the book
of hebrews
and
this issue is very very prominent
in the book of hebrews
the excellence of the new covenant as it
is in christ
and the consequences of the rejection
of this
new way of approaching god
are
horrendous
so when we look at it there's a quote
here in early writings
page 213 which says i saw that god had
forsaken the jews as a nation i must be
very careful here not as individuals
correct
that's so important yes but that
individuals amongst them will yet be
converted and being able to tear the
veil from their hearts and see that the
prophecy concerning them has been
fulfilled
they will receive jesus as the savior of
the world and see the great sin of their
nation in rejecting and crucifying him
now martin if you cling to the shadow
which pointed to the greater reality
then having rejected the greater reality
and clinging to the shadow are you then
still
under
the covenant promise of god no
didn't the doesn't the bible say having
a nulled the first he implemented the
second yes
what is the word the null mean martin
complete it
fulfilled
done away and away with done away with
your house has been left to you yes
desolate that yes
what is that empty empty empty
so empty that it could be destroyed
if you now
want to rebuild that house
and re-implement
the sacrificial system yes are you busy
with the shadow are you busy with the
substance with a shadow you're busy with
a shadow
so can there be two covenants
one
that is active in the shadow and one
that is active in the substance no
it's not possible no
it's not possible because the shadow
pointed to the greater reality yes
i i used the example of a tree
a tree casts a shadow
and by looking at the shadow
you can see that you're dealing with the
tree
right you can determine roughly the size
of the tree
you can determine how it's standing is
it upright is it skew there are many
things
the size of the leaves you can determine
many things from the shadow can you
climb the shadow no
it doesn't hold your weight right
so
the substance is what it is about
and the substance is
arrived at by faith
in a completed work yes
and the substance of the shadow is
christ correct
so if you do not accept christ
are you then part of the covenant no no
it is a sin
yes
the sin of nick the book of hebrew talks
of neglecting so great as salvation
so unfortunately if we look at the
nation of israel
the house is desolate that's biblical
the first has been annulled it no longer
exists
they clung to the shadow to such a
degree
that they were willing to proclaim it is
better that one man die
for the sake of the people in other
words our religious
shadow system
than that the people our religious
community and shadow system should die
for the sake of one man
so they clung to it and they rejected so
great a salvation
therefore this quote
is absolutely biblical and the promises
according to the scripture
were transferred
to those who believe
correct the promises
went to spiritual israel the spiritual
seed of abraham
who believed god and it was accredited
to him and therefore to them also as
righteousness and that hasn't changed it
was the same in the old testament the
first covenant had exactly the same
criteria
if they clipped if they held on to the
faith that they were supposed to they
would have seen the messiah for whom he
is
and not went like you just said
and rejected him good when when we do
the series on the book of hebrews
which we will be doing shortly
then this contrast
should become very clear
it's difficult in in one
answer
of this nature to to cover the whole
thing because after all
the whole world has been swept into this
kind of thinking all the eyes on
jerusalem
the whole
world's eyes are on jerusalem where they
expect the building of the third temple
now the second temple not one stone was
to be left upon another what does that
mean spiritually
not
one stone
not one peg if it were a tent not even
the cornerstone is in there nothing it's
gone it's done away with
it has been annulled it has
been replaced
and this is the important issue now
where does the state of israel actually
come from in modern times
is it born
out of a biblical concept or is it born
out of a masonic concept
it's born out of the masonic concept but
they use biblical scripture to try and
justify it yes but they distort the
biblical scripture that's the thing
so this is a a a
masonic concept
set up with
finances from the my sonic
fraternities
and then
the very nations
that it was made with do not even
comprise the people that are currently
there to a very great extent
because many of these were converts to
judaism so they are not from the literal
tribe of judah
so there are many many issues here that
we need to discuss and we will be doing
that as i say
in fullness in the book of hebrews thank
you i think we can conclude with that
yes will you close with that for us with
a wedding prayer please
a loving heavenly father
christians are so important
and there's so much confusion out there
in the world
help us to be grounded in your
word
to believe
what is written
to take it to heart
to compare scripture with scripture
to make sure that we are on the right
path
help us to rightly divide the word of
truth is my prayer in jesus name amen
amen
thank you for watching this video
to subscribe
click here
when the bell appears
click again to get notifications to
watch the next video
click here